-Our next guest represents
Massachusetts'
7th Congressional District
Please welcome to the show
Congresswoman Ayanna Pressley.
Thank you so much
for bein' here!
-Thank you, Seth!
It's great to be with you.
-You are spending quarantine
with your husband;
your stepdaughter;
and you have a cat,
a cat of note.
-Yes. Her name is
Sojourner Truth Pressley Harris.
We call her Sojo.
She's got a mean
resting feline face
and, you know, we love her
She's great.
-She's a large cat, yes?
-Okay, now, watch it.
This is a body-positive
household, okay?
-[ Laughing ]
-I know that I showed her
to some of your producers
and there was a little bit
of a reaction.
She is fluffy.
-Okay gotcha.
-She's got no problems.
Body-positive, okay?
-Alright.
Understood, understood.
-[ Laughs ]
-She is exactly the cat
she is supposed to be.
-Exactly! Exactly.
We love her.
-One of the things
the squad is addressing,
the progressive wing
of the party is addressing -
I think, you know, in general,
everyone in the country should
be addressing right now --
is the racial disparity
of how this pandemic
is affecting this country
and that the inequality
that was baked in before thi
is what is leading to that
How do you, one,
address it now, in the moment,
in the middle of a crisis,
while, at the same time,
trying to address
the root causes of it,
to make sure
it doesn't happen again?
-Yeah, the thing is
the inequities
and racial disparities
that we see playing out,
spotlighted and exacerbate
during COVID-19,
have been systemically
entrenched and embedded
for a very long time.
So, anecdotally, we already knew
how this would trend
and how this would go.
And so, early on, myself
and several of my colleagues
began banging the drum
for the collection
of racial data in real time,
the disaggregation of it,
the public reporting of it
so that we can ensure that
our public health response
is equitable, both in testin
and access to treatment.
You know, here's the thing
is we started out behind.
We are in the worst position
ever, that you wanna be in
in confronting a pandemic,
and that has everything to d
with the criminal negligence
the science denials,
press briefings
that have really functioned more
like disinformation campaigns,
and the sluggish response
of this administration.
So we're behind.
And so data,
and, particularly, racial data
is one way that we get
ahead of that,
so we ensure the resources
follow the data
and they are directed
to highest infection rates
most vulnerable communities,
so we can do mobile testing,
antibody testing,
contact tracing,
and all of those things
that are in the best interes
of the public health.
And then, after that,
you know, I think
it's why we have to suppor
our community health centers
We have to address
health disparities --
the comorbidities
of structural racism,
the impact
of climate injustices,
of food injustices.
That is why Black
and Latinx communities,
which are food deserts;
transportation deserts;
higher rates of asthma,
because they disproportionatel
bear the burden
of environmental injustices;
have been more susceptible
COVID-19 doesn't discriminate.
You know, anyone can
contract the virus.
But these communities --
my community --
is most susceptible
to contracting it
and, when we do, suffering
the most severe consequences
-You've talked about this
as a crisis within a crisi
and, obviously, you know,
Congress is having to addres
so much that is going
wrong right now.
Do you feel as though
Democratic leadership
is being helpful addressin
sort of this angle of the
situation we're in right now
-Well, you know, myself,
community members, activists
and my colleagues, we're focused
on putting the people first.
Not corporations,
not private,
not profit, not corporations
and focused on the acknowledging
that this is unprecedented hurt.
This is a tsunami of hurt.
And experts recently said
that, you know,
maybe 90% of these
infections and fatalities
could've been stopped,
had we acted sooner.
And so what I'll be focused on
in upcoming relief packages is
"What do we do in the mids
of this unprecedented hurt
that provides
the most relief for people?"
And that's about getting cas
in the pockets of people
as quickly as possible.
It's about more testing.
It's about canceling
student debt,
canceling rent and mortgages.
It's about including
our immigrant neighbors
who have been excluded today
from every relief package.
It's about supports
for our most vulnerable --
those experiencing homelessnes
and living in shelter,
and also incarcerated
men and women.
And then, beyond that,
I just want to say this --
the fact that we needed
a moment like this
to prove to us
who are essential workers.
They've always been essentia
and they should've
never been treated
as if they are disposable,
and that's how
we've been functioning.
They should be working
at a living wage.
We could've already
addressed that.
We must do that in the future.
Having hazard pay,
paid sick leave,
paid family and medical leave.
So the path forward is tha
we've gotta move boldly.
When people say they can't
wait to be returned to normal,
normal, Seth,
was unjust, insufficient,
and inadequate, to begin with,
so this is an opportunity,
both in addressing
the racial disparities
and in centering the humanit
and the dignity
of every individual,
of every family,
of every worker.
Then, we've gotta go bold.
Think about how we
would've weathered this
if we already had
universal healthcare,
if people were already working
at a living wage,
if we already had
universal paid sick leave
and paid family medical leave.